well the pride of the x-men ever make it
back to the big screen or a plans for a
kitty pryde feature officially fallen
through the floor in a recent sit-down
with comic book Deadpool director Tim
Miller discussed the long-awaited solo
feature for fan favorite mutant Kitty
Pryde which he had been developing
before Fox Studios acquisition by Disney
earlier this year
his comments were were sorry to report
not encouraging before the
much-ballyhooed merger Miller had been
all set to direct the flick from a
script by comics legend Brian Michael
Bendis pride has been a Marvel mainstay
for nearly 40 years with her ability to
phase through solid matter and her
quirky sardonic sense of humor she
quickly endeared herself to readers
helping to propel sales of x-men comics
into the stratosphere in the 80s the
character seems like she would have been
a fine fit for Miller who did an
excellent job of bringing Deadpool's
ass-kicking profanely humorous aesthetic
to the screen in the Merc with a mouth
first solo outing likewise it would have
been fascinating to see Venice's
big-screen take on the character among
the many heroes he's created for Marvel
over the years as Jessica Jones a tough
complex female character who translated
well to live action in her unfortunately
canceled Netflix series but
unfortunately Miller has confirmed what
many fans anticipated the Kitty Pryde
project is dead in the water Miller said
I love the x-men
I don't expect Marvel to call me and say
come to the x-men so I'm not waiting for
that I was really excited about my Kitty
Pryde movie it'll never happen now hold
it kitty Miller's comments are a pretty
radical departure from Bendis response
when he was asked for an update on the
project this past February in a response
to a fan query on Twitter
Bendis said that he was working on the
script at that time failing to even make
mention of the impending acquisition of
the studio which had greenlit the film
alas things seem to have taken a
significant turn for the worse for the
project in the intervening months and
that's not all the bad news that Miller
has had to endure as of late his second
feature directorial effort Terminator
dark Fate flopped mightily at the box
office despite relatively solid reviews
making it another franchise that
probably won't be coming back anytime
soon
were of the opinion though that the
Helmer shouldn't be quite so pessimistic
Deadpool was a rousing success
single-handedly proving that r-rated
superhero pictures were viable in
today's age of non-stop
pg-13 blockbusters it remains to be seen
if Disney will bring him into the fold
to put his talents to use with a new
Marvel property but it'd probably be a
good idea to reach out well nothing is
official yet all signs are indicating
that Marvel Studios will eventually give
the green light to a third Deadpool
movie at some points in the near future
star Ryan Reynolds who was born to play
the role has openly expressed his hope
that the threequel would get greenlit
sooner rather than later and the writers
of the first two installments Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick are confident
then it's just a matter of time before
the flick is put into production for
that matter Marvel Studios brass have
indicated that they expect to eventually
recast every member of the x-men except
Deadpool and Disney CEO Bob Iger has
publicly said that the mouse house would
be just fine with Marvel making an
r-rated superhero film add this to the
fact that Reynolds was recently seen
popping by Marvel Studios offices for a
visit and it all adds up to the strong
possibility that we'll get some news
about Deadpool 3 before too long other
than a potential third outing for
Deadpool though it looks like every
single one of the Marvel related
projects that were in development at Fox
before the merger are dying on the vine
the Channing Tatum starring gambit in
development for the better part of a
decade recently received a vote of no
confidence from formerly attached
director Doug Liman
Logan director James Mangold had said
that a planned spin-off featuring Daphne
Keens x-23 is unlikely to happen and
James Franco's multiple man failed to
reach a significant stage of development
before the merger meaning that it too is
almost certainly done for it simply
makes more sense for Marvel Studios to
develop these characters for the screen
in their own inimitable fashion rather
than to continue on the course that Fox
was plotting especially after the
critical and commercial failure of the
final Fox produced x-men film Dark
Phoenix having said that a Miller
directed Bendis scripted Kitty Pryde
flake sounds like something we would
want to see
and if Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige
has any designs on introducing the
character into the MCU he could do worse
than to bring the pair in for a chat
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]